passports please anything to declare
visa and customs free transit between
Poland and Kaliningrad has been
suspended for now it used to be possible
for local citizens to cross the border
without any formalities but that ended a
few weeks ago a small sticker in Russian
and Polish passports allowed those
living close to the border to cross over
easily
now Russians need a temporary Schengen
visa which costs 35 euros but with an
average income of 500 euros that's a lot
of money yes it's not easy it's hard to
get a Schengen visa you have to
specially organized a trip to Poland you
have to book a hotel or you need to have
an invitation from a good friend in
Poland or in the EU also use it local
border traffic drew people from both
sides together and boosted local
economies for example in the Polish
border town bar to shih-tzu now entire
rows of shops wait here in vain for
Russian customers from Kaliningrad to
granny's name
I think they should reinstate the local
border regulations because of the
business it draws in the locals and the
Russians and it's good for small
businesses everybody needs something
from someone sashimi or sukhasana the
most expensive attack until recently bus
loads of Russian customers were shopping
at the big supermarkets here
this morning there are only a handful of
them a visit to a Polish supermarket
helps them make up for the scarcity of
goods back home we buy diapers coffee
and fresh food all the things we can't
find over there or things we can only
get at low quality but the dwindling
trade with Russia isn't affecting Polish
exports which have risen by more than 8
percent since 2014 Russian looks like a
huge attractive market but if you look
at the figures that's really not the
case the Russian market is more like
Spain's
Russian consumer spending power is not
very high temptation is - malwa the
border is becoming increasingly
impenetrable for people and goods
suspending local border traffic has
moved Poland and the EU a little further
away from Russia